vice president kamala harris is still
with us as our exclusive interview with
her continues
madam vice president these are such
difficult times we were all still
reeling from the shootings in atlanta
the flags have been lowered half-mast
and we're back up and now they're
lowered again
for what's happened in colorado but many
people are very frustrated about the
shooting in atlanta because it has not
been called
a hate crime should it be
listen i mean gail look you've got
six asian american women in asian
american businesses
um and you know that just
when you look at it you have to ask this
question
which is what is going on and the the
seriousness of
aapi hate crime especially over the
course of the last
year is profound um people
are being assaulted people
are being you know cursed out people are
being
treated people are being denied service
because they are asian american and look
i think we have to be clear that we have
a history in america that we need to
deal
with a history that included the chinese
exclusion act
as a law um that we interned
japanese americans who also fought for
the liberties of americans
um in in war and and and we have this
rise in hate crimes when i was attorney
general california
i published a hate crime report every
year it's not new
but it has grown and it must be
confronted and dealt with
what do we do well what do we do a
number of things one
we have to hold the people who commit
hate crimes accountable
we also need to speak the truth about
our history and not
gloss over it we need to also talk about
what we must do to to really think about
how we define who is an american
and understand that it is the very
essence of the strength of our nation
that we are a land of
immigrants people who have come from
around the globe here and have
contributed
to our vitality our strength and
and and and all people are part of that
the chinese
help build the railroads of america
isn't it holding
people accountable though at least
calling it a hate crime i think
in atlanta they it's it's been now a
week they still aren't calling it what
you know it's like if it looks like a
duck walks like a duck smells like a
duck it's a duck
and there's been such reluctance to call
it that well i'm not prosecuting that
case so i'm not gonna tell you right but
i will
but i i've spoken very clearly about it
which is exactly
that we we are looking at a situation
where asian women have been killed let's
also talk about
the reality of of of race and and and
sex in terms of
the intersectionality of it all and what
we have seen in terms of
crimes against asian women in particular
in our country
recently and historically yeah your
voice matters in this conference madam
vice president
the white house has been criticized by
members of of its own party for not
having enough
asian americans in the high levels of
the government at this point senator
danny duckworth in particular
very critical of the absence there
what's being done to change that are
there enough yeah
well anthony you're right well first of
all let's just speak truth
representation matters
and when you look at the composition of
the united states congress less than
four percent of those serving in
congress are
asian american aapi asian american and
pacific islander
you look at the ceos of our major
companies and corporations in america
less than three percent
are asian american niapi so we need to
talk about this
representation matters and we've got to
address it
we are very proud that among our cabinet
we have majority people of color we are
very
and it's historic in that way we are
proud that we have an equal number of
women and men
but there's still more work to be done
there's no question about that
let's take a look at what's happening at
the border rightly or wrongly people are
coming in record numbers because they
believe the biden administration has
encouraged
certainly children to come what are you
going to do about that it's chaotic
some are calling it a crisis and you all
the your team is under fire because both
republicans and democrats said look if
you're going to
change the trump policy the previous
policy at least have a game plan and
there doesn't
appear right now to be a game plan
well okay look it's a huge problem i'm
not going to pretend it's not it's a
huge problem and
are there are we looking at overcrowding
at the border particularly of these kids
yes should these kids be
in the custody of hhs the health and
human services instead of the border
patrol
yes should we be processing these cases
faster
yes this is however not going to be
solved
overnight there are things that we need
to do especially since there was a
system in place
previously before the last
administration to allow us to process
these kids in their country of origin
that was dismantled we have to
reconstruct it it's not going to happen
overnight
but you know we we have senior
administration officials right now in
mexico and guatemala
also dealing with in addition what needs
to happen at the border
will you and the president be going down
to the border anytime soon
at some absolutely we will go down to
the board and i've been down to the
border
um and and and our secretary of the
homeland security
alex mayorkas has been down there twice
senior administration officials have
been down there
and yes we will go but the reality also
is that in addition to the border
um we also need to deal with the root
causes we need to deal with what's
happening in the northern triangle
we and address it in a way that is about
not only diplomacy but bringing our
allies together dealing with
um with what we need to do around aid in
a way that is about
developing those countries so that we
also deal with the cause of why people
are coming into our country
that's a long-term proposition in the
meantime there are five hundred people
i understood but there are 500 children
a day and we don't have enough housing
already who are crossing into the border
what do we do in the meantime to stop it
well we do what we need to do to
actually reconstruct the systems anthony
that are about processing these cases
and that is taking some time look we've
been in office less than 100 days
we're addressing it we're dealing with
it but it's going to take some time
and are we frustrated are you frustrated
yes we are
are you enjoying the job and then we
gotta go
yes or no i am enjoying this job thank
you i feel
very i felt a great sense of
responsibility to make sure we address
the needs of the people
everybody's watching thank you very much
vice president good to be with you both